Travis luke says,
why are dragons in western culture bring yourself death and destruction that
must be slain while in the east?
They're portant of good fortune to be revered?
Well,
that's a great question,
by the way.
Um,
the,
the Dragon,
I already defined the dragon at some point,
partly from a book I read a while back on dragons as a tree cat,
snake bird.
The idea in the book was that the Dragon was a imagistic representation of the
class of all predators,
which means also might be why dragons.
Um,
also breathe fire because fire was undoubtedly a common destructive agent in our
evolutionary past.
But the dragon is the most primordial cysts symbol of that which looks beyond,
which is known.
In fact,
it's even more primordial than that because it even is that which lurks beyond
what is unknown in some sense.
Remember Don Rumsfeld,
unknown,
unknown unknowns.
Well,
that's basically the drag.
There's some unknowns that pop up that you can master right away and you can
kind of think of those as known unknown's.
But unknown unknowns are those things that pop up that you don't know about.
You didn't even,
you had no idea whatsoever that they even existed anyways.
What's the character of an unknown?
Unknown?
Well,
part of it's terrifying because it can,
it can,
it can do you in,
right,
but part of it's also positive and and because it,
anything that's truly unknown brings it with it.
A tremendous amount of new possibility.
That's why dragons hoard gold or why they also heard princesses or guard
princesses hoard,
I would say is the right word.
So I don't think the dragon in the West is a fully negative symbol because the
dragon has gold associated with it or virgin.
The reason for that is that the hero who confronts the Dragon gets the Virgin
and that hasn't changed.
That's,
that's a story as old as time and I don't think it'll ever change as long as
there are human beings now why the Chinese put stress on the positive side and
the West put stress on the negative side is difficult to say.
I might say because the Chinese got organized so early,
I have a sneaking suspicion that it was easier for them to see.
A little bit of chaos is something positive,
something necessary and positive as a counterbalance to the tremendous
organizational weight of their state.
Um,
that's the best,
best answer that I've been able to formulate.
Um,
so,
so anyways,
the dragon is a very complex and ambivalence symbol.
It,
it combines everything into one symbol,
positive and negative,
and then you can stress the positive or you can stress the negative.
You could also say to some degree that whether a dragon is positive or negative
depends to some degree on the manner in which you approach it.
Because the psychological reality is that dragons approached voluntarily,
well,
small are most likely to be positive.
And that's a really good thing to know in your life.
Uh,
it's a good reason.
It's a good rule of thumb to help you stop avoiding things that you shouldn't
avoid so that they don't grow and magnified beyond your capacity to deal with
them.